es francia market quiere ser la primera
vicepresidenta afrodescendiente de
colombia
ha cambiado la tarima en la primera
vuelta presidencial por el contacto
humano en esta segunda ronda visita
comunidad por comunidad
este es su cierre de campaña en base a
los pies de la cordillera de los andes
mientras desayuna escucha a los posibles
votantes algunos ya están convencidos
incluso seguidores del partido
conservador
nos vendan la idea de que nuestra
cantidad de agua está preparada los
críticos le achacan falta de experiencia
acaba de irrumpir en política pero su
liderazgo social y ambiental se remonta
a sus 13 años cuando inició una lucha
contra la minería
'francia márquez ha recibido amenazas y
tiene un gran esquema de seguridad para
muchos colombianos es la forma de hacer
política
santamaría
[Aplausos]
por la tarde las citas en el centro de
calidad
[Aplausos]
la tercera ciudad de colombia está muy
cerca del océano pacifico una de las
principales concentraciones de población
afro aquí en colombia nunca ha dejado
gobernar a una persona que sea gay
también atrae el voto de las mujeres
laura marea cantautora de medellín
feminista piensa que la vicepresidencia
es el paso previo a la presidencia yo
creo que ella lo que está haciendo es
ganar espacio y abrir espacio para que
muchas más personas como ellas tengan
acceso al poder quiero ser su hijo
presidente
así es como francia market decide
terminar su campaña entre los indígenas
y mujeres los nadie a los que quiere
representar desde la vicepresidencia